President Trump claimed vindication
today in his latest battle with the
media fake news media had me calling
immigrants or illegal immigrants animals
wrong
they were begrudgingly forced to
withdraw their stories the president was
pushing back against headlines that took
his words out of context the AP had
tweeted Trump referred to those crossing
US border illegally as animals CNN
tweeted the quote these aren't people
these are animals as having happened
when Trump criticized u.s. immigration
laws
now aap has deleted the tweet and one
CNN anchor clarified things this way
when he appears to be very clearly
responding to a comment about members of
a violent gang here's how the story
unfolded you wouldn't believe how bad
these people are these are people these
are animals but what was downplayed or
ignored was that Trump was responding to
California sheriff Margaret Mims on the
frustrations and tracking ms-13 gang
members ms-13 gang members I know that
they don't we just roll
even now some journalists aren't quite
accepting the president's explanation
the White House now says he was
referring to the criminal immigrant Geng
ms-13 not to all immigrants but he
didn't say so
Trump defenders immediately claimed that
the president was only talking about
members of the gang ms-13 which is not
true I refuse to allow this president to
kind of define good immigrant bad
immigrant because the litmus test at
this point is simply that people who
were not born in this country our
animals president Trump is open to
misinterpretation when he uses sweeping
incendiary language but in this case
some news outlets went far beyond his
words and the Fuhrer keeps growing
despite the media's Corrections and
clarifications